[Musique]
j'étais triste mon coeur était rempli de
tristesse
je ne te voyais plus petit bonhomme je
ne voyais plus petite fille petits
n'enfants mais tout ça va changer
je suis là en chair et en os pour une
nouvelle saison de on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge saison 2 alors donc cette
nouvelle saison va faire quoi
on va voir les producteurs les artisans
on va élargir l'horizon de nos
connaissances et on va bien sûr passé de
super moments ensemble alors comme vous
dit bonjour la réunion bonjour la vie
bonjour tout ça là nous les agents petit
chez monsieur morel sur son exploitation
ensuite on va aller là-bas sur la
montagne voir un petit peu sa table
d'hôte et puis ben comme d'habitude que
me pourrit jason suivre ma maman m'a
bien
[Musique]
c'était
alors je me suis montréal jean gilles on
à la volaille joliveau light taz niveau
live et pas dans nos parcs installés
dans la nature comme cela et des tomates
et là nous savoir li savoir li dans une
nécessaire on va faire un petit peu la
connaissance de monsieur jean jules
allons où êtes-vous monsieur jean ou et
à comment ils les ont hués là où ça va
super alors déjà mais aussi d'accueil à
nous normal normal non alors devant un
petit peu en bref où ça nous les échos
ça vous fait à nous les agents petit sur
l'exploitation agricole de monfils et de
moineaux produit essentiellement ainsi
les tomates sous serre tomates tomates
ail et les poules ne pourra les poules
et poulets tous les passionnés de mal
aux sites dont bien sûr qu'au cap l ah
bon these connaissez ça et après c'est
un coq
vous connaissez vous laissez pas comme
joueur et donc
donc voilà où on produit aussi de poulet
nos produits des des poulets des poules
est essentiellement destinée à la table
d'hôtes d'accord mais destiné aussi à
des consommateurs que nous qui nous nous
l'avons construit une petite hutte il a
beau pour abattre les poulets avec un
petit vécu fruits fait que nous nous
inscrire un ou deux ans des manches ou
nous asservir un produit d'une certaine
qualité
du certaines qualités et nous le
recommencer déchire un petit mois quand
on dit d'une certaine qualité en fait
l'ac lydie pas parce que lui tu vas le
même pas ils vont tailler mes mamies
mais la possible les passions en format
a4 le type ou la non non non brigands
balle dans la tête dans un bar tout le
monde peut jouer
[Musique]
alors on a vu les geôles du poulet mais
aimerait que ou démentir plus de
précisions là nous donner des idées aux
serres kosovo le processus pour le pied
de tomate que les letchis coma est
arrivé de noix ou des tomates que le
processus est quoi la difficulté c'est
point de journées comme ça dans l'étau
macquenoise hainaut cultive des tomates
sociale et malek cultivés dans des sacs
des sacs qui contient des fibres de coco
est d'accord ce qu'il appelle la culture
en sol est vrai que le mot soit un petit
peu galvaudé les gens ils pourraient
crois que nous cédé qu'au mondial des
empoisonneurs alors que dans ce type de
culture là dans cette façon de conduire
des crocs d une culture mais croit que
nous c'est nous qui gaspillons le moins
d'eau le mois de fethi lisant et le mois
de produits fixes en était un
néna quelques quelques insectes
prédateurs des insectes nana soul et
c'est que nous élève nous là une petite
une petite société
émanant de notre coopérative qui permet
à nous de combattre plus facilement
c'était un prédateur sur les tomates et
qui évite à nous de faire beaucoup de
traitements sur les wii / sur les
cultures chose que les plus impossibles
à l'extérieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean je donne un petit coup c'est pas un
secret quelles variétés de tomates ou
nana ici alors nous fait essentiellement
de vérité thomas nous fait l'olivette
gmail très bon il n'ya pas ça
olivette parce que c'est la fonderie
thomas caricom 10 et cruel et nous
produire des tomates rhône
essentiellement médicalisé les bombes
l'impôt vert il faut qu elle vient de
récolter les écoles et bureaux
il faut attendre le ces photos n'ont
aucun joueur donc et en gros ont même
failli être maintenant avignon me croire
que nous doit cultiver une vingtaine de
variétés de tomates tout le monde à la
toute qualité ou là des variétés millet
modène croiser une à des variétés
anciennes de variétés anciennes comme la
noire de crimée la rumeur mais que les
produits de manière assez confidentiel
quand même très peu de la très peu de
producteurs qui qui fait ça en grande
quantité parce que c'est des tomates qui
coûte un petit peu plus cher à l'achat
peut-être et que les fragiles et très
fragile le transport de soi même et avec
un qualités gustatives que les nettement
nettement meilleures
mais me parce qu'il vient au fait
monsieur au fur et mesure le
consommateur les demandé à deux de
produits que l'un peu plus un peu plus
goûteux et peut-être un peu plus
respectueux de l'environnement d'un
automne nous aussi peut-être espère
belle moka nous voulons qu'il soit
bref au cadran bada 8e bollaert lillois
comme du gramoune où la jolie cac rhodia
fait deux hectares et demi plus en étant
fermé trois hectares et demi dans la
6000 mètres carrés de cultures sous
serre en grande partie pour l'instant
que les encore friche
lorsque l'exploitation on est en train
de muter d'ici améliorer d'ici deux ans
parce que nouveau visage de transformer
cette exploitation en fait mme noura
essentiellement du bio
[Musique]
auxerre avec des pieds on va dire plus
ou vinyle cd que c'est une culture qui a
22 jours après soit en même temps là
pour pouvoir commencer à fruits à partir
de la plantation saison ici de moins de
deux ans et demi évidemment me voir me
vois des moments des petites de type
papier comme ça avec des couleurs bleu
jeunes c'est pour faire joli dit pas moi
ça et pas de papiers pas pu nous
pratiquons nous appelle la lutte
biologique intégrée sous les 7 lors les
assecs et comme nous les attirer pour
des choses le triplé attirés par la
couleur bleue
ibm et yahoo de savoir le degré
d'infestation la parole il permet aux
serveurs degré d'infestation de cette
population là sous les serres et ça
c'est pour ces pour la mouche blanche la
mouche blanche les attirer pour la
couleur jaune et ça c'est dans un piège
que l'aigle les gluants quand il arrive
à lui pose dessus
gagny décoller ayez pu décoller ne
combat pas avec ça mais pma ou d'avoir
une idée de la population glace où cela
sert tous les petits carrés tatata quoi
là mais tout ça il permet à moossou vue
d'éviter de faire des rapports plus
qu'il n'en faut
drôlement
au lendemain du tout
mon dieu
combien de mon travail était à la une à
trois salariés d'école sur
l'exploitation de trois 3 salariés que
nous emploient depuis dix ans dix mois
la citronnelle ça aussi l'époux à éviter
les bains n'est pas chasser les insectes
l'idée a pressé de mettre plutôt des
bandes fleuries d un équilibre entre les
les plans qui attire les plantes tir au
push pour donner un peu d'harmonie
surexploitation mais c'est bien chouette
tout ça c'est bien chouette hein bien
content d'après beaucoup de chose à
l'esprit comme un petit peu le but là
maintenant pousser quoi tous les lundis
tous les lundis et jeudis nous récolte
ne me fais pas d'une coopérative nouveau
grandes surfaces et ea aux gens que nana
des fruits et légumes noix psa
bazardiers ici et nous fait un peu plus
de 5000 tonnes bien oui mais nous ne
ferons pas ça c'est le nombre
d'adhérents c'est un petit coopérative
une coopérative où nous retrouvons nous
devons nous retrouver des valeurs nous
retrouve des gens que l'on vit de l
envie de partager
certaines valeurs et une façons de
produire une façon de commercialiser
n'est pas facile de mettre de mettre les
gens avec ou ensemble
[Musique]
naudy jean-jules aller voir un petit peu
son monde et animaux à rabat il fait la
connaissance de jonathan qui ont fait
quoi ici vous faire un stage où
travaille rapidement discours il a
encore l'école et en même temps de
travail je vais préparer ce plat mais
des théâtres ph alors même si ça pose
une question simple est primordial c'est
quoi un bon tomates comment vous
connaître ma de l'éprouver peut être
cassé pour récolter et pour finir son ca
l'action google soit dans carrie romain
bruit et pacifique est d'accord et où
pour le coup ou voix haute à venir dont
willy et ça n'en fait pas spécialement
tomates mais en tout cas dans le monde
agricole en général et ben brahma et il
a placé un travailleur oui voilà comédie
- et félicitations là mais content mais
ça fera pour la peine je l'attends nous
retrouve des bonbonnes journée à eau
[Musique]
banjul a beaucoup fait un bilan
cosmonautes ne me dis pas que tu vas sur
la lune non voilées mois toujours été
passionné d'apiculture c'est informel
avait un grand nombre de ruches mais là
maintenant on a plus que 5 6 rue juste
pour les besoins du gîte et ma
consommation personnelle dérange par
houcine y tient un peu éloigné juste
pour déconner mais il n'y a pas on va
dire qu'on va dire que allez vous
donneront les plus téméraires
[Musique]
l'armada un petit peu dans les hauteurs
autre grand coup de théâtre petit tout à
l'heure à 500 mètres de là nous un mille
cinq cent mille 500 mètres et nous les
doors jim d'accord où on a mangé mes
enfants des petite crête avec de la
confiture de tomates et du miel mais
elle maison bien surface et pallie fait
le miel et les abeilles on est d'accord
on va contourner un petit peu le
pourquoi du comment pourquoi la dona ou
cette idée pourquoi ici où sam hamad du
village même d'ailleurs aimé à grands
coups de navarre contre mon petit peu
mieux connaître tout le monde et qu'on
soit ce j dc su ce terrain-là que vous
gens n'ont pas travaillé comme
journalier à l'école dans un endroit
complètement perdus ou n'est pas le
chemin boileau pour l'électricité est en
fait me crois que c'est ce type de
structure là aujourd'hui que dont les
gens là besoin la vie est belle un fonds
d'un coup tu nous vit simplement un
mauvais simplement nous et c'est de
délivrer 2 délivre un message de frais
un message d'appel message ou mais pense
que tous on né peut retrouver maintenant
une voix au 3e tour en tout cas j'espère
nous retrouve médium et c'est encore moi
mais ça va aller à plus tard les enfants
bisous cadum
[Musique]
à
voilà l'émission se termine mon petit
que les gros maquis de jongieux donc la
visite à nous lasser onana les tomates
ou l'expliquent nos petits petons
comment comment tout ça se passe à
nouveau des 100 un petit peu avec une
vue sur le village de grand coude n'y
pense juste comme ça un petit anecdote
mais pense que on devrait faire un petit
peu plus attention aux sentiers de grand
coude donc un petit peu de l'axé c'est
un beau village et je trouve qu'on
devrait axer sa sur le tourisme juste
comme ça une petite idée moi pour le
coup je redescends dans les bas c'était
la première de la saison 2
oui on va se voir souvent maintenant le
dimanche et les autres joies aussi pour
le coup parce qu'il y aura des rediffs
et qu'est ce que je voulais dire ah oui
on n'est pas mais alors pas du tout
sorti de l'auberge
salut la compagnie messieurs et dames à
plus tard
[Musique]